now some breaking news for you nasa's
team has recommended a no-go for launch
to the director of the artemis one moon
mission just
hours before it was expected to blast
off from the kennedy space center in
florida well these are live pictures of
the nasa rocket on its launch pad well
the launch was cancelled last week due
to engine problems well alan fisher
joins us live now from the kennedy space
center in florida alan what do you make
of this
well we should know in in a very short
order of time whether or not this launch
is going to go ahead they've been having
problems over the last few hours to get
the rocket off the ground you've got to
mix liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen
liquid oxygen there's been no problem
filling the tanks there has been a leak
as they fill liquid hydrogen
that has they've tried to fix it they've
tried at least three different fixes and
now the team there has recommended to
the launch director that they scrap this
for today till they try and get to the
bottom of it particularly as the launch
window is approaching it's only less
than three hours away now
and so the launch director has decided
to take that advice and then we'll make
a decision very shortly it'd be a big
disappointment to the thousands of
people that have gathered here on the
space coast in florida hoping to see
this mission which of course would be
the first step in taking humans back on
to the moon there'd be two other
missions after this before that actually
happened but people here were hoping
that they would see a moon launch it
looks as if because of this slight
problem it's not going to happen of
course the big question is then when can
it be done now if this can be fixed
quite easily
obviously more easily than doing it
where it is at the moment then they
would hope to be able to get the rocket
up into the air in a launch window that
they've got on monday they might have to
make the decision that essentially the
rocket has to be wheeled back into the
workshop and that could well delay
everything until mid-september but
things should become clearer in the next
hopefully 10 15 minutes certainly we
expect to get some sort of clarification
within the next hour and alan how much
of a setback would this be for nasa if
indeed they have to wait till september
well look they've had problems all the
way along
this has been delayed covert delayed the
the whole process of building the units
that they needed and then there were
other issues that ran massively over
budget
would it be a problem it would be a
slight glitch but i think overall nasa
and the administrators are looking at
the big picture about how important this
mission is how important it is to
establish a base on the the moon which
artemis iii would do sometime they think
around 20 25 if the current time scale
were to be followed so it would be a
glitch it would not be a welcome glitch
but there's absolutely no way they would
approve a launch when they're not 100
certain that everything will go smoothly
so
hopefully we'll get some sort of
clarification as i say in the next hour
but it's not looking good for the
they've tried a couple of solutions to
fix this leak it's on the outside rather
than the inside uh when plan a didn't
work they moved to plan b they then
tried plan c someone who's at the space
center said plan c was essentially plan
a slightly modified that clearly hasn't
worked which is why they're saying look
the launch today might not be a good
idea and they can take 48 hours and have
another go at it and how bad does this
look for nasa image wise then if it
doesn't actually happen yet
oh yeah
well i think people understand that
there can be glitches with these things
you're talking about massive rockets
there are so many systems that have to
go
exactly right and everyone remembers the
disaster of the the challenger space
shuttle no one is going to take any sort
of risk if there is anything that could
possibly cause a problem
so nasa would much rather say look we'll
wait another day and go again
rather than do something that that could
uh
really set the whole program back by a
significant amount of time so it's
really just a case of of working through
the process finding out what the problem
is
the people at nasa are really smart
people like
really super smart so if there's a
problem there they should be able to
find a solution it's just whether or not
they'll be able to work that solution
within 48 hours or we need something
more significant something more
substantial and take the rocket back and
essentially pull apart the part that
needs to be looked at and get it all
done from scratch and then look again at
a much later launch all of that we're
hoping will become clear very soon
indeed well for now alan fisher thanks
very much for that update
well going to the moon is about more
than just exploration it's part of a new
international space race to exploit
lunar resources the focus is on the u.s
right now but other countries are
investing in their own missions
russia has announced plans to withdraw
from the international space station to
focus on its own interstellar goals that
includes putting humans on the moon by
2026.
china is targeting 2030 to put people on
the moon it's also planning to build the
very first lunar base in collaboration
with russia by 2035
and india has already sent two unmanned
missions to the moon and it's hoping to
send a third lander next year
the united emirates which opened its
space agency eight years ago plans to
send a probe as early as november
elbaz is a former nasa scientist who
worked on the scientific exploration of
the moon and the planning of the apollo
program he joins us from washington dc
well first of all what do you make of
this uh situation with the artemis
this is perfectly normal the uh the nasa
engineers
at cape canaveral for launch would not
allow anything to uh to occur or to
continue if there is a potential problem
so this is this is very good for them to
make absolutely certain that the uh the
rocket is in perfect condition and and
to allow the launch on time
are we now in a new space race though do
you think
yes we indeed we are in australia since
china is now entering in a big way
china has been thinking about it for a
while but has not really entered in into
the space program in a big way the
soviet union was the soviet union was
the leader
remember in 1957 in in november 1957
uh
russia sent the very first satellite
into earth orbit was called the sputnik
and
so russia was leading and then america
led
by through the apollo program and now
china is entering this scheme and russia
china wants to say we are as good as
anybody else if not a little better
because they want to land on the far
side of the moon and they want to do all
kinds of other other things so china is
entering the space program in a big way
i understand that you worked on the
apollo program all those years ago i
mean do you still feel that sense of
excitement now
indeed because we were working on the
program and all of the engineers were
working very vigorously and the
the
battle cry at the time was
go do this thing and do it well and do
it fast do you want the ruskies to beat
us that's the way the engineers talk
meaning go and do this thing and do it i
have to absolutely do the best possible
way of doing it because you don't want
the russians to beat us so there was
this
uh competition going and it has the
program and now there will be another
competitor china which is good
i think competition is very good in
these cases and nasa is talking about a
future base on the moon to prepare for
missions to mars even is that feasible
or just science fiction
no no no it's feasible quite feasible
carry because they we we've already
shown to the world that it is possible
to lend humans to work on some planetary
body like the moon and to get back
without
no problems they can sustain the
radiation from the sun and all of these
other things and the the it is possible
to
to think about long-term missions to the
planets like mars so i didn't think it's
coming someday
and with this artemis mission what kind
of experiments will they be looking at
people say or might say does this
benefit us on earth
yes they will bring samples and they
will bring
water samples and that is very important
to say that there is water in a
planetary body like the moon and
therefore there may be water on mars and
therefore we would not be we would not
have to transfer
water to any group of humans that would
travel there
to to these planetary bodies so the
availability of water is something that
is new and is something that would
provide additional
impetus to go further than the moon
and what about the cost of all this
though is it worth it
the cost is not really for the space
mission the cost is for developing all
kinds of new technology the reason that
i'm talking to you and you could see me
in my picture and i see your picture and
people everywhere in the world can see
our pictures in south america or north
america or in china that they can see us
and canadas
that did not come from somewhere in
somebody's mind that came from spending
money for the apollo program so that we
would be able to see the astronauts so
it's a be able to direct them that's
what they'll be able to see if there is
a problem there so all of the
technologies that were developed for the
apollo mission to the moon is now in the
computer business because the computers
themselves the best computer was a
computer tool
to can be carried on the
ruler
machine so that they can actually
verify their position looking at stars
so that there to make the calculation
which is very tough calculation now all
of these calculations can be done on any
computer that you can carry in your hand
all of this came from the apollo
exploration of the move or the results
of the experiments for these missions so
whatever is being spent
on the potential missions to the moon
and to mars is beneficial to all human
beings on earth because it provides the
technologies that we can use like
computers like the imaging that is the
picture that you see today the picture
that everybody can see around the world
all of that came from the apollo
research
farooq elbaz we very much appreciate
your time thank you very much for
joining us
thank you